Kevin Hart here Paterson New Jersey of
course I'm not by myself I'm with some
funny funny gentlemen ty Rainey CJ
cregg's Kendall shorty war and Ray Gibbs
how would you guys describe your style
of comedy it's more personable
it's about myself my experience is like
coming from what I don't want said
little dudes perspective okay but uh
yeah a little dude to make eye contact
with me I consider myself a very large
male does the family support your craft
are they all about the movement the
comedy movement my girl wants me to get
a job some of this is all we get back
home depot lapse on the bed they don't
believe do y'all feel like comedy is
more it's more sensitive today than with
it than what it was back in the day I
mean for the most part being younger in
the game I think sometimes you you want
to make sure you ain't doing the wrong
thing or stepping any toes or anything
like that sometimes you get rules and
regulations when you get to a show so a
lot of time to just you know helps you
adapt okay you know biggest bomb moment
word show ever that's what I want to
know right now I do prison tours
Pennsylvania the inmates are there they
take chillin just nothing separating us
from the ambitious bleachers yeah a
floor and me I've done one yeah I've
done one so long story short I wasn't
getting to the funny or the punch of my
jokes and there was this one brother
that was just sitting in the front he
had this long goatee and you're just
staring at me like this and I was like I
I'm not getting any reaction from
anybody I just looked at him I was like
brother do you want me to go up the
stage he just loved to chase it
absolutely
next time
[Music]